[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
andrew whitworth super bowl champ and
walter payton man of the year and now
he's officially retired andrew joins us
on the program andrew thanks for joining
us did you know during the super bowl
that that was your last game
i knew kind of going into the playoffs
that that was probably going to be the
last run i was going to get to make i
knew the body was starting to talk to me
a little bit finally starting to feel
40. so uh i knew it was a pretty good
chance this is probably the last run i'm
gonna make
but when does it hit you where you go
this is it i'm i'm gonna be i'm retired
or has it hit you
it really hasn't hit me yet i mean i'm
still training with the guys you know i
think we've talked about before the
o-line trains at my house a little bit
in the off-season so i'm still working
out with them and hanging out with them
and doing all that but uh i'm definitely
done this is it i'm not playing anymore
uh right up until about a month from now
when i tell you differently yeah but
brady said the same thing
yeah exactly and that's the point i mean
i don't you know that's what's wild is
it's not really a physical decision i
mean yeah you start to
feel it a little bit as far as it's more
pain than normal but
right now do i think i could get through
another nfl season without a doubt i
just think that
a lot of the things i set out to
accomplish in my career i've been able
to do and
uh i got some awesome kids and a great
wife at home that i'd love to go spend
some more time with and and watch them
play sports and watch them live their
lives a little bit
i think that's just kind of where i'm at
what was your favorite moment in the
huddle from the super bowl with matthew
stafford
you know
there's so many the guy's so rare he has
such a rare demeanor about him when he
competes it's so fun to be in that
huddle with him um he's such a
gunslinger and a guy who just wants to
go after it at every moment
uh and just attack and really just in
that game really him being in that hall
throughout the game really in the
adverse times and then also in that last
drive the demeanor he had of like we're
gonna make this happen i thought was so
special and then honestly when he got in
that huddle and just tried to tell us
that we were gonna take a need in that
game i can remember how emotional he was
and he went to talk and instead of
talking he just looked at everybody in
the huddle and was like i love you guys
and then he just you know then it was
like all right ready break like you know
we're about to do we're taking a knee we
don't even talk about it
uh it was it was really cool to see how
much emotion was there of really what he
realized that he had accomplished
so it hit him then that he was finally
gonna be a super bowl champ and he
couldn't get the words out
yeah you could tell just for a second he
had to just he looked in the huddle he
looked in those eyes and that's the
coolest part right i mean when you play
football there's all these great moments
that happen individually and all the
passion that goes into it but when you
look across that huddle the guys you get
to do it with
sometimes those those moments are the
most emotional because you realize man
we all did this together we've all
strained
we've all fought through things together
all kinds of adversity and we're about
to take this need in this game and be
world champions
and it just kind of hits you what it all
i was wondering if you felt sorry for
the bengals offensive line during the
super bowl going against uh
aaron donald
i feel sorry for every team that has to
play here i mean that guy is
he's one of the rarest humans on the
planet man he's his work ethic and
attitude is is really what sets him
apart he has all these insane physical
traits that make you special but there's
a lot of guys walking around
in this league that have been drafted
with a lot of talent
he takes advantage of that talent with
his work ethic and his demeanor every
day to attack success it's it's second
to nobody i've ever been around and uh
quite impressive i mean i remember
going in a week after the super bowl to
the facility to grab like my stuff you
know i'm still barely gonna get it
together i've been partying and having
so much fun and aaron donald's aaron
donald's just pounding weights and
running in the gym and i'm like
this guy's not going anywhere
what did you keep from the super bowl
what's that what'd you keep from the
super bowl
you can't ah everything
you name it
yeah held onto it all and i you know
what i didn't even um
wash my jersey i literally left it with
all the stains it had on it i'm gonna
eventually you know wash it off a little
bit just so it doesn't smell but i want
all the war paint on it i don't want any
you know let's leave all the paint on
there
and i want it to look like it played in
that last game and
half the time that i know i did do you
have neighborhood dads who want to try
to rush you and see if you can block
them
well you know dan it's one of those
things it never fails being big it's
like i've heard every big joke possible
you know and it's like it's just
constant you know it's like oh man come
up with something original and i'll
actually laugh i like to give them kind
of the stone cold face stand just when
they when they literally like if it's
not a good joke or it's one i've heard
before i just stare at it and then it
makes it really awkward because they're
like well i thought that was going to be
funny but he's not laughing
i was also wondering about this as a
lineman you don't get to see much of the
game
like you're focused on the guy in front
of you
have you ever gone back to look at the
game to actually
see what they get because you could be
down on the ground on a pass play you
don't even know what happens
yeah you know it's the truth it's um one
of those things i always tell a lineman
when i mentor them hey look man you're
one of the rarest athletes in the world
you're the only athlete in the world
that plays with their ball plays with
the ball behind your back like your
backs to the ball
the entire game you don't ever know
what's happening other than when it runs
by you so uh it's a pretty rare position
so yeah i mean for me it's that's the
funnest part right go back and watch the
game and be like all right i want to see
every little intricacy of how a guy got
open or how a running back made the cut
or you know a pass that stafford threw i
mean the first time people started
talking about his no looker to cooper
there late in the game against the
bengals this is the first time i saw it
too
it's unbelievable
uh your favorite sean mcvay story is
going to be what
oh man you know there's so many i mean
him and obviously with our relationship
there's a lot of really uh special ones
a lot of fun times we've had
um
i think really for me it's gonna be that
i think the coolest part of what made
sean mcvay really the build-up to who he
is as i tell people this a lot when we
started otas his very first year a 30
year old coach
who you would think needs to come in and
show guys that he under he knows
football at a really rare level to be
where he is and you'd think that he's
the first thing you're going to do is
talk about football and i can remember
our first three or four weeks of otas
we focused on the words character
communication
uh you know performing an elite level
being at your best when your best is
required you know just typical things
that have to do with who you are as a
person day in and day out and how you do
things the right way and i thought that
took a lot of gumption to be able to do
that as a 30 year old but also it set
the standard for why he's created the
culture he has and the rams and and why
it's such a special place to play
but it feels like he's this close to
wanting to put on a uniform to prove
that he could play
right
uh yeah look there's plenty of moments
of sean hurting himself
uh pulling quads and and uh everything
else you know he never fails to miss an
opportunity to kind of show us that he
still has a little something in there
um you know but it only lasts for about
about a second two seconds you know it's
just a quick little step here there
uh so it's it there's plenty of those
moments you know hey he he without a
doubt always thinks he's got a helmet on
when we're out there well congrats and
uh perhaps we'll cross paths on a golf
course with uh some mutual friends there
i look forward to it i can't wait i'm
gonna be spending a little bit of time
on those too thank you buddy
hey thank you uh andrew whitworth won
the super bowl he played 16 seasons and
uh he was the walter payton man of the
year